لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
الفلسطينيون يشيعون شهيدين قتلتهما قوه
الاحتلال خلال اقتحام مخيم عقبه جبر
باريحا الاحتلال لا يقول ان موقعا له قد
تعرض لاطلاق نار بالضفه دون وقوع اضرار
ويعلنوا رصد ما وصفها بمحاوله فاشله
لاطلاق الصاروخ من جنين وفي غزه كتائب
القسام تقول انها استولت على مسيره
اسرائيليه
قصف مدفعي متبادل بين الجيش والدعم في
اندرمان وتحليق مكثف لطائرات الجيش
بالخرطومه وزاره التعليم العالي تقرر
ارجاء فتح الجامعات والامم المتحده تدعم
مجددا لوقف فوري للقتال وتقول ان اكثر من
14 مليون طفل بحاجه لمساعدات انسانيه
صحيفه فينانشيلد تايمز تقول ان السعوديه
والامارات بدات موجه شراء لالاف من
الرقائق الالكترونيه من شركه انفيديا
الامريكيه لتطوير انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي
لديهما في وقت تسعى فيه شركات التكنولوجيا
الكبرى لتامين احتياجاتها من الرقائق
الخاصه بتطوير هذه الانظمه
قضيتنا امريكيه تحكم لصالح الشبان يتهمون
ولايه مونتانا بانتهاك حقهم دستوري في
العيش ضمن بيئه نظيفه وسليمه من خلال
تشجيع الشركات العامله بالوقود الاحفوريه
في قرار وصف بالتاريخيه في اول محاكمه
مناخيه كبرى في الولايات المتحده
الى اللقاء